alors pourquoi tahiti qu'est-ce-qui
temps mais je viens chercher l'aventuré
c'est qui ce gars là qu'on sait comment
naviguer complètement seul mélange de
manque de sommeil mal de mer et
d'hallucinations aussi au bout de
quelques jours
pourquoi tu fais alors c'est une
sensation difficile à décrire notre seul
devant l'affinité de l'horizon
et m
que diriez-vous de ramener le asian en
californie pour moi qu'est ce que t'en
dit chan dick parcourir six mille
kilomètres c'est de la folie
j'irai nulle part ce toit mais les voilà
avec quoi bon alors on prend en vigueur
inattendue
il vient de passer à la catégorie mag
commençons par tout sécurisé à bord est
ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter
je t'aime
et ça carbure
oui ça
résa ça va je vais m'occuper de toi on
est à des milliers de kilomètres de la
terre ferme
loin des trajectoires de vol une zone de
recherche de quarante mille kilomètres
carrés où ton chercher une aiguille dans
la sueur est ce que quelqu'un m'entende
je les côtes cassées une fracture et
monsieur poids mort
ici on rejoignait hawaï autant viser une
cible mouvante à 3000 km si tu m'as
okawa si je mens kawaii on meurt j'y
arriverai pas été capable de réussir
tout ce que tu veux
j'ai navigué la moitié du globe pour te
trouver
je te laisserai pas mourir